good morning Millennials how you doing
hi guys I'm here with Olivia today I
don't know if we explicitly told the
toaster that you were going to be
Wednesday's episode in studio with me
cuz you know this week is a bag of of
Randomness a bag of fun no I just posted
on my Instagram story that I was on the
toast so mostly to share that I'm
wearing my natural curly hair on the
toast which is I literally the first
time I've ever publicly done anything
with my natur hair I talk to us about
this decision well because I woke up
this morning I had so much to do I
didn't really have that much time I
showered and like obviously if you have
curly hair or just in general you know
like when you start blow drying your
hair and then ironing it you start
sweating like I wasn't in the mood to
come here sweating and I was like you
know what I'm just I'm going for gold
like I'm just going to embrace who I am
no but I don't think we've ever done the
toast together in studio not here not
ever no like maybe maybe a long time ago
in the you know pink background first
toast Studio we definitely did it
together when CL was on tour but
definitely not in the Last 5 Years and
certainly not in this studio and the
only reason why I fully know that is
because I get to sit in Claudia seat
which is more my side and so like when I
replace you and I sit over there like
I'm always 100% more uncomfortable
because like I my body doesn't turn that
way you know yeah Claudia got the good
side when we started a show 7 years ago
and it's fine I've made this side my own
and now I like it yeah no you can
anything so you're good no I I yeah it
is what it is if I had like could if I
had my brothers seven years ago I would
have chosen that side but it was more
important to her everyone know yeah
there's something about this side like
if you ever look people actually notice
it sometimes I've gotten like a few
comments about it but like you'll never
catch me in a photo on that side I'm
either in the middle or like on this
side got it I just it it's not
comfortable you don't have a reason for
that I'm telling you it's cuz my body
only turns this way you're like
Zoolander I just like I can't I don't
know it's just always been my thing and
it is what it is it is what it is well
I'm so glad that you're here we haven't
we actually we podcasted together a few
months ago but it was Audio Only so now
we're in my studio flamingos which is
just a fun treat Claudia is in La
podcasting from dear media Studios and
we're just having a nice random week
yeah you know like I also never wear
pink and like only when I come on the
toast I pink to like match the vibe I
feel like I have to like get into
character yeah no pink is very toasty
I'm wearing green which is also toasty
um it's crazy that like you're wearing
pink and I'm not no I know and if you
know like the last time I was on the
toast of Cloudy I wore pink too and
those are probably the last two times
that I've worn pink what do you think
are you feeling like you want to wear
more pink um it's such a great color it
is such a great color I just also really
love this sweatshirt so I made sure to
wash it last night but like with these
you can't really dry them so it had to
be like washed and hang dried so it was
like a whole thing of getting ready when
they dry they lose their magic yeah yeah
I need to like not wash them at all but
like I get spit up on them oh I'm
disgusting yeah so it doesn't work out
every time I leave the house I look down
and I'm like how does this have a
[__] stain on it like every every
everything I own has stain on it
permanent stain stain that happening
this minute honestly like I'm shocked
that I don't have like coffee all over
me right now you know yet it's still the
morning is still
young this is actually my second coffee
today already oh but I raided your
fridge for some coffee because you need
coffee you need coffee to do the toast
and that's what we're going to do today
we have a great show for you guys today
we have five stories you know a lot of
similar stories in the news this week
which is going to be more fun to talk
about today because I want to get your
take on a few of the most popular
stories and we're going to do dear
toasters and I feel like everybody needs
Olivia's advice in their life I couldn't
think of a better host to accompany me
for de to so excited it's a lot of
pressure you know it is but I feel like
I wonder if we're going to give the same
advice because if we don't then it's
less pressure cuz it's like you got both
yeah now do what you want paths now you
choose uh so I wonder if we're going to
be this same the thing about deer
toasters is like when you initially hear
a story I feel like or a situation you
have like an instant reaction and then
like the more you ruminate on it like
you kind of come that's like talking
with a friend 100% you got to talk
things through that's what we're here to
do yeah I mean talk away girly I will so
we're going to get into all that but
before we do let's catch up with altivia
how are you doing what's with you I'm
hanging in Saw well today is actually a
very special day because today is my
Levi's birthday happy birthday
my baby is one um and honestly like I
could cry talking about it only because
like it's gone by so fast and I think
I've said this before but everybody's
always like you know enjoy it soak it
all in it goes by so fast and it is like
such annoying advice but then when you
really think about it it goes by so fast
and I'm just like where did the time go
you know yeah and I feel like for me
both and any child baby born period is a
miracle but like my two pregnancies were
so different different and for their own
you know reasons had their own
situations and so like when I just can't
believe it's a year already and I'm so
excited to celebrate so I'm excited to
celebrate too I'm excited to give Levi
his gift I'm not going to spoil it but
I'll let everyone know yeah later on
yeah I know what it is I told you no how
do you know because I brought your
packages in and it was so obvious I know
so annoying I wanted to surprise you I
know it's sick it's actually the most
epic gift ever like you're so creative
you know
darn darn darn I know like literally
when I roll it up I'm like what the hell
is this and I'm like it could only be a
birthday resident for Levi but you saw
that I have it oh wait no no no no what
you think you saw it was not Levi's
birthday present yeah cuz I know what
you there was like a vesa that's not his
present I don't know that was a baby
gift um for Charlie I don't know who
sent it it wasn't on my registry a very
cool gift so I need to find out who sent
that that is not Levi's present okay
surprise surprise but you did bring in
Levi's present too I don't know what it
is um and okay I'm so excited you don't
know what it is we'll tell the people
later what you got yeah because now the
surprise is intact yeah it's intact but
that vesa was sick I was like this is so
cool yeah I mean Levi's welcome to play
with it I'm sure he will I mean Kayla
I'm sure actually will take it because
yeah but that's so funny I took Michaela
to the store yesterday to go buy a
birthday present for Levi and she picked
out a book for him and she picked out um
this like kind of like wooden laptop
desk situation which was super cute and
so she gave it to him this morning and
when we opened it up she grabbed the
book and she's like this is mine and I'm
like well she picked it out girly pop it
ain't yours but like she picked it out
cuz she liked it and so now it's like
wait but it was for someone else that's
a hard concept to wrap your head around
it is it is like gift giving I know and
I probably like did it all wrong cuz I
also let her pick out a gift for herself
that I bought her yesterday and I was
like this one's yours and these are for
Levi she only saw a gift and she saw her
and that's it and everything she thinks
is hers you know even Harry's thing she
thinks it's mine that's her favorite
yeah literally so yeah it's a special
day 10:18 and obviously I feel like you
know when I shared that Levi was born
last year I never told anybody I was
pregnant so it was like crazy town and
like can you believe we a year from that
yeah it does feel like a year though
does it yeah for me oh that's cool it
does not for me but I also feel like the
reason why it does is because I was
actually thinking about this this
morning the first year of your baby's
life is shorter than the 9 mons that
you're pregnant with them like the
pregnancy just feels so long and I feel
like because you really like got
pregnant like the month after Levi was
born I feel like that's why it feels
like long a year cuz it's it's been a
long year for me right yeah 100% so yeah
okay well I'm excited to celebrate yeah
me too happy birthday happy one year of
motherhood like of you know of being a
boy Mom no one like the first year of
baby's life whether it's your first
second or whatever like is a milestone
for Mama too 100% it's a celebration for
you getting through year one which is a
crazy year it is a crazy year but I feel
like right after kind of like six seven
months which for Levi was when he
started like sleeping through the night
that's when the tide turned the first
six months are so hard even if you get
your kid to sleep at like 3 months like
it is very difficult just in general
and when you're in it it feels like it's
so much and then it goes so fast and
you're like how did I even get through
it you know yeah so yeah we're through
it year baby yay okay so let's get into
the stories I'm so eager to get your
take on all things pop culture right you
know I I'm like an adjacent pop culture
girly so I don't even like really know
how much I can say because I don't like
know anything about anything but I know
things I love I like a different Vantage
Point like someone who's not so in it
like what does someone you know who has
other interest Hobbies think about some
of these stories that are taking over
our lives 100% so today's episode is
brought brought to you by skims you guys
we love skims skims is creating the next
generation of underwear from every for
everybody it's so true I wear skims in
my everyday life there fits everybody
collection literally fits everybody I
love the scoop bralette and all their
different colors onx sand clay their
t-shirts they fit so well they're so
flattering the fits everybody collection
of underwear is super lightweight and
molds to your body finding the right
underwear is something everyone has to
go through at a certain point in their
life and you can just skip over all that
work and go straight to the skims fits
everybody underwear because it is the
best underwear The Buttery soft fabric
stretches to twice its size without ever
losing shape meaning you get a perfect
fit every time and it's available in
sizes xxs to
4X do people call it xss that's a m
extra extra small yeah I guess I could
have just said extra extra small yeah
anyways you should believe the hype
skims has over 990,000 f-star reviews
for a reason the fits everybody
collection and more perfect fit
Essentials are ail available now at
skims.com plus you can get free shipping
on orders over $75 after you place your
order be sure to let them know we sent
you the toast select podcast in the
survey and be sure to select our show in
the drop- down menu that follows you
guys please do that well first of all
get your skims because it's
life-changing and everybody needs like
great solid well-made Staples in their
life but then also let them know your
girl sent you so that um credit by the
way that's such a good ad for the toast
because like I own skim undies and I
feel like after your mom like your belly
just hangs like I'm sorry it just does
and like it you need that material to
like suck you in but that's comfortable
because you have to wear underwear all
day yeah it needs to be like like fitted
and snatched but you need to be comfort
and that's literally what skims is it
and snatch but comfortable I feel like
is like Theo of this family you know
like and how you want to live your life
so yeah our episode today is also
brought to you by game time you guys we
love game time here at the toast because
we love concerts we now love sport
Sports and game time is the place to go
to to get your tickets I've had so many
frustrating ticket buying experiences in
my life there was a time in my life I
was literally going to a con like three
concerts a week and I wish that I had
been using game time at that time
because they have the best last minute
tickets they have such good deals I
never got a good deal on some of the
other services like I was just I feel
like I was just getting fleeced yeah
it's so much better to buy it last
minute actually too because who can make
plans these days so true and you
shouldn't have to worry when you're
buying tickets to your next big event
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals all in prices
views from your seat and their best
price guarantee game time takes the
guess work out of buying tickets so you
want to go to the game time app check
out upcoming events in your area like
concerts we love sports as we said we
need to go to some sporting events down
here we have so many teams that we can
support by the way 100% And you know
what I always say ever since we moved to
Florida the Florida teams have been
amazing I know and it makes you think it
makes you think you know like it's
literally and you're just getting into
sports like it's all the things all
combined you know right so game time is
the only ticketing app that gives you
complete peace of mind with your
purchase you can see the view from your
seat before you buy so you know exactly
what to expect when you arrive I love
that I hate having to like hold my
breath like what are these seats that I
bought game time makes it so easy you
can take the guesswork out of buying
tickets with Game Time download the game
time app create an account and use code
toast for $20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code toast t o a s for $20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
guaranteed we love when things are
guaranteed I love you guys are you ready
for the stories I'm ready baby let's do
it okay the first two stories like have
the World by the balls today um okay pop
culture World actually I should I should
State cuz there are other things going
on but first Marin Maris files for
divorce from Ryan herd after 5 years of
marriage so documents obtained by people
confirm that she filed on October 2nd in
Tennessee citing a reconcilable
differences as the reason for the
divorce this is like shocking to me yeah
documents state that the pair who share
a three and a half-year-old son Hayes
have been separated since the filing
date which is like two weeks ago two
weeks ago yeah a parenting seminar was
ordered by a judge on July 25th and
indicated that Mars and herd would have
60 days from the date of their filing um
to filing their complaint to complete
the seminar but on July 25th documents
indicate that Mara successfully
completed a 4-Hour parenting skills
seminar on October 14th that's weird
that is weird on July 25th what is that
uh the seminar it's a requirement for
all uh divorce cases involving children
in this County that they filed in got it
okay so maybe there was another filing
no but like if so it started things were
moving on July 25th but then the divorce
filing happened on October
yeah I mean I think one of the reason I
obviously saw this news and then so I
started to try to sleuth around so
neither of them have made a statement
yet this is like purely just in the news
they found the docks exactly number one
they got away with it for two weeks yeah
but also Ryan herd had posted something
I think like September 20th like this
almost like Love Letter to Marin and her
new music that was like really
supportive and loving husband esque um
so again based on the information that
you're sharing if things had gone Ary
like come July like it's
so interesting that he did that in
September you know well I feel like you
know things take a while to deteriorate
especially if you have a child like I'm
sure you're trying to make it work
trying to make it work and like even if
they filed on October 2nd like things
were probably bad for a while but I
could imagine a world where like he
respects her so much as a musician and
like as a person because they both are
musicians where it's like okay maybe you
didn't work out as my wife but like I
support what you're doing and you know
she made this big statement with her
music and with herself like saying she's
leaving country music and so he must
have very much agreed with everything
she was saying and like wanted to come
out and speak out her yeah I mean I
think my take on the situation having
absolutely zero contact so I obviously
say that upfront um I think it's
probably very hard to be in a
relationship where you both kind of
started here together like they met
writing a song together where they were
both um really unknown and then like her
like star rose really fast and like he
just didn't take off in the way that she
did I actually personally like a lot of
his music um
and he he's a great musician but
obviously like he never you know he's
not like Luke com's level of country
right or of just music in general he's
kind of I would say you know doing his
own thing and maybe more of a I think
he's a songwriter also like he's I know
he's also written some lady a songs I
think um not 100% sure of that but I'm
I'm almost positive on that um so I
would just imagine it's really hard to
be in a relationship like that where
someone is like so much more famous than
the other but you both kind of started
at the same place and both want that you
know because like she was on tour and
like he was just kind of following along
and I think you know I think he probably
did as good of a job as he could
supporting her for as long as like his
heart could take but there has to be
some level of jealousy there you know
how do you really deal with that yeah
well they're the last of a of three
country couples that were in this
position so first it was Casey Musgraves
and Rustin Kelly and it was the exact
same thing like she's more successful
but they both do the same thing Kelsey
ballerini and Morgan Evans who also bit
the dust last Here and Now Marin and
Ryan and I feel like when the other
couples you know divorced we compared
them to the other ones in this situation
then Claudia and I like always said you
know who does such a good job of like
even though it's not equal in terms of
success they support and they love each
other and they're having a successful
marri Carly parse Michael Ray oh yeah
but that was like that crashed and
burned like real fast yeah yeah but then
and then her star really took off but
that wasn't like a a su that's not this
it's successful marriage and also they
got married at all like the same time
and they were all it was just very
similar situations so I hate to like you
know generalize and be like you know the
men can't handle the women's success I
do think that plays a part in it but I
really felt like Marin and Ryan um I'm
on first name basis with both of them I
really I I felt it was different in this
situation like I don't think that's it
okay okay that's super that's the only
thing that I can I'm sure it doesn't
help things like it can never be helpful
when two people are trying to do the
same thing and one of them is having
more success than the other like that's
hard but I don't think that's the only
reason like it was in some of those
other ones I think the other thing
that's different about this one than the
others is that they do have a child
together true yeah they have a son but
maybe that's also why they held on
longer right 100% yeah mhm yeah well
honestly I hope that you know I hope
that they navigate this as amicably as
possible and that ultimately they are
both happy yeah and based on you know
the statement he put out when they were
clearly getting a divorce he has love
and respect for her and it's not nasty
as of now yeah sometimes people just
don't work out but that doesn't mean
that they absolutely hate each other you
know yeah it's very rare but I think
that you know some people are capable of
that which kudos to them yeah yeah so um
damn damn rip I mean I think that on
both sides there'll be some new music
coming out about it no oh yeah you know
yeah for sure so we wait and see yes
another bit of relationship that kind of
has the world shook because Sophia Bush
is in a new relationship with Ashlin
Harris they both had their first date a
few weeks ago and they're both beginning
new chapters cuz they're both recently
divorced so a few weeks ago Sophia Bush
like made waves cuz she was getting
divorced it didn't really like mean
anything to me cuz I'm not like a
follower of hers and I didn't watch that
show she was on yeah One Tree Hill yeah
I only know her I think she's on one of
the Chicago Chicago Med or something
like that CU you know that's more my
vibe is like the dramas you know yeah no
but like for some people like Sophia
Bush is there um
Beverly Mitchell no stop that's so funny
did you watch yesterday's episode of the
toast no oh my God Jackie Shimmel was on
and there was literally a five minute
conversation about Beverly Mitchell
because Jackie shim had just run into
her at Awan oh and when she brought
Claudia the Smoothie which like that
clip I did see um and it was absolutely
hilarious no I was going to say like
Rachel bson you know Misha Barton like
that VI 100% Beverly Mitchell is just
like maybe five years prior you no no
bever some people's Beverly Mitchell is
Sophia Bush and honestly for Jackie shim
it
was um so people were really shook about
the news about her divorce and now
they're shook once again because she is
spending time with professional soccer
player Ashlin Harris so A source told
people that after being friends for
years and running in the same circles
Sophia and ashin went out on their first
dinner date a couple weeks ago this is
so recent and they are both beginning
new chapters it's also worth noting that
Ashlin Harris is a female soccer player
from the women's soccer national team
and she made waves of her own because
she was married to one of her teammates
right right right and they and they got
divorced um it began a few months ago
and they've been living apart since the
summer so on both sides fans of both
parties are like you know shook by the
news yeah no this would be another one
where I would be interested I don't know
if you have the data but like on the
timeline CU I think I saw that Sophia
Bush she announced her divorce like in
the last like 10 days or so um and she
had only been married for 13 months I
think or something like that okay um and
then when was the other divorce
announced and how long were they married
for I guess it doesn't really matter I
think this is great listen ultimately
this kind of goes back to the Marin of
it all which is like if you're not happy
in your
relationship go find your happiness like
seriously I mean that doesn't go back to
Marin that would like just be no no I'm
just saying I'm trying to tie it
together to the first story that goes
for everybody everywhere like if you're
not happy in your relationship go find
your happiness yeah also um Ashlin has
two kids with with her
ex so there's a lot going on here yeah
there is um The Source said that Sophia
and Ashen were friends for 10 years and
bonded
during hold on there's so many yeah yeah
there's so many intricacies cuz the
story that I saw was that they went to
dinner with Stacy London oh is that in
that article this was about Sophia and
her husband were friends for 10 years
and bonded during Co through their love
of community service so I guess okay and
then they got married then they got
married then they got divorced got it
yeah so sometimes people are better off
being friends yeah yeah no I'm
interested to see how this all unfolds
you know yeah um like I feel like the US
Women's Soccer Team we were like such
soccer girlies as kids you guys ever
talk about that on the toes like we did
travel soccer every weekend we were so
no because like we all played soccer but
I feel like when I think of soccer like
I I don't feel soccer is us not Claudia
yeah yeah yeah even though she played
two and Margot played two but like we
played together yeah and we played a
long time yeah we played until until M
high school and then we played in high
school yeah true yeah and we played on
the same team yeah so that's why it's
like our thing no offense Claudia Maro
yeah but then I went to tennis no but
tennis was also our thing was a
different season no no but we played all
throughout growing up yeah no no I know
I'm just saying like in high school
sports like my high school sports
memories are me playing tennis yeah but
I guess I played soccer too but I don't
know it's not it's not as at the
Forefront of my mind playing tennis in
high school isn't as I think we had to
choose you probably chose tennis and I
CH soccer I think that's exactly right
yeah yeah look at us Sports we really
sporty always don't like I feel like you
know also people like say that but I and
we don't talk about it that much but we
were so sporty we were such tomboys we
were such tomboys we were like
sweatbands for years and you would just
never believe it you would never believe
it because also it's not like we're the
sportiest now but even still like if I'm
you know in an intral League when that
happens like I'm crushing it everyone's
always so shocked at how athletic yeah
even when we were at iol we played
softball kickball both both yeah yeah
yeah yeah no totally I think that I met
Zach cuz I was in intral corporate
League 100% um yeah we were we have
really always been Sports girlies and
also just not to like tie it and make it
full circle but it really is when you're
talking about like interiror leagues
like that just made me think of camp
like we were so athletic at Camp you
know always playing sports and running
and doing things like kids naturally do
at camp so it all ties together camp but
we were also like the top of the Heap
like yeah sure everybody has to play
sports and like go to sports activities
but like we were you know starters we
were captains like we were those girls
100% And that's worth clarifying I think
that that also we W like riding the
bench no we were not riding the bench we
I was first singles all four years of
high school that's why like tennis is so
at the Forefront of my mind and now that
I'm trying to get back into it it's like
really disappointing how bad I am
because I didn't play for 10 years yeah
that's something that goes quickly tenis
I mean honestly we did a lot of things
as kids that we kind of gave up and I
truly regret it you know like piano we
played the piano forever I can like I
can play Heart and Soul yeah we were
playing like coner to like people don't
know that you were like a like cello
teen phenomenon you know I don't know
about phenomenon but phen cello you were
so good at it I don't remember being
like so good I it was bigger than you
yeah but I just remember like playing
you know I took my lessons and I was you
were really good you were really good
that's really nice no you were I think
also I played the clarinet okay I played
the clarinet for one year I played the
violin for like two years I played the
guitar for 5 years and I played the
piano for like nine or 10 who's counting
no because I think about it a lot now
where it's like oh my God I wish I still
had those skills and even if I just like
kept up with it once a month like I'd be
better than the zero I [__] am now
you know yeah and I that's it's also at
the Forefront of my mind now that I
think about like what my kids are going
to get into and like how can I just
really prove to them if you do do
something like just kind of make it part
of your personality and don't just do it
and then like Drop It When You're 15
Because by the time you get to be 32
like you'll regret it you know yeah life
lessons life lessons well our next story
is about Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce
but I have a lot of things to say
because uh Travis Travis um they went
out you saw their weekend in New York
City right some of it yeah so Saturday
night they went to dinner at noou then
they both guested it on SNL for a second
then they went to after party on Sunday
he went to the Jets game to see his
brother play he left her apartment and
then they went out to dinner again was
he wearing an outfit similar to what you
were wearing now when he left out her
apartment oh yeah oh my God this is like
Jets what do they say Jets coated yeah
AKA it's Jets colors yeah no honestly
there's so much it's hard to keep up
with that's why I'm like some and now
that you're repeating everything I'm
like okay yes I I saw noou I saw I heard
about SNL I didn't see it I saw him
coming out of her apartment in a green
kind of like tracksuit Vibe I think um
so it's like hard to keep up because
it's everywhere but I don't even like
effing know what's going on well what's
the craziest thing about it like of
course he's the best tight end in the
league but he's also a podcaster and so
every week he has to do a podcast with
his brother and like talk about their
lives so like every week he is like
addressing things that are happening and
so he talked about he's denying pushing
her security guard because in the videos
of them walking like he lightly Taps the
security guard he said I didn't push him
I placed my hand the gentleman's back to
let him know I was behind him and also
like to let him know like bro I'm taking
the lead here he said if I would have
pushed him he probably would have turned
around and tased me 100% yeah no can we
go back to the podcast for a second yes
and I also just want to talk about the
brothers Kelsey because I just started
the documentary Kelsey which you watched
and that you loved loved yeah and I also
want to get your lay person's opinion of
this couple yeah okay so much to unpack
there so let me start um I'll start with
the brother Kelsey because truthfully
the funny thing and I don't know how far
you are in the documentary so just let
me speak freely okay that's fine it's
not really going to be spoiled they
really started the documentary about
Jason about Jason the brother because he
was like going to retire yeah um and so
the documentary is really about him like
figuring out you know his postretirement
life strategy so they started the
podcast thinking that the podcast was
going to be like something for him to do
after he wasn't going to play so it's
like it's just so funny how like life
happens that way because now I think
they're more in the spotlight than ever
before and they have this platform which
I think is great because you get to hear
from them directly firstperson wise on
everything that's going on instead of
all the media speculation with like fake
information my real question on this
entire situation though getting back to
Travis is like really it makes me think
that they've been together a lot longer
than people think because they're being
so public now it just happened so fast
there's just like you and you know like
when you're dating somebody new like you
try to keep it under WRA CU you don't
know where it's going to go like I just
feel like for both of them you know
obviously he had his own esow and has
been very open about like dating in his
life but like she is the complete
freaking opposite so something to me
makes me feel like they have been
hanging out for a while and when he put
his tweet out I think it was a tweet
about you know wanting to see her um on
tour like that kind of got think they
were hanging out before that yes I do oh
I do I don't think so and typically I
would agree with you like they need to
be together and like you know very solid
for a long time before they're going to
go public that's how I feel about like
Kylie and Timothy like they but I don't
feel that way about this like I feel
like they had a few dates they really
enjoyed each other and there's no really
keeping this under wraps especially if
she like wants to go to his games and
like try and have like a normalist
relationship and support her boyfriend
and I think that they're both also I
think they're so into each other and
just like in this like honeymoon phase
and they're also loving how much people
are loving it it's like you know what
why not date publicly even if it ends
badly it's it fun while so much fun it's
fun for everyone I don't yeah no listen
I see both sides I think that it could
be 100% both that is just like one
conspiracy I guess that I that I feel
could be true because of just the way
that it absolutely happened so overnight
and it's it's not even that yes it's so
public it's her tailor being with his
mom in the bo do you know what I mean
like you know you don't really meet
someone's parents a week after dating
them or a month even you know like it's
it's so fast on so many levels yeah but
I do think it's really fun I think it's
like exciting I think listen I'm not
from the swifties like I like her music
but I'm just not you know I didn't go to
her concert and I I think like what she
does is great like don't get me wrong
like I like her music I'm but my
personality is like I'm not Super Fan
dummy you know I'm just not like I'm a
Swifty no I like some unless it's in
sync I if they are they going back on
tour did that I think they're feeling
they're putting out feelers like they
put out this song I will be in the front
row will the San Hood lives on I will
get a game time tickets and I will
[__] be there wow okay well you know
what that's actually a great segue to
our next story if we've put Taylor and
Travis to bed yeah know the one thing I
wanted to address about Taylor and
Travis is I love that the Beckham
documentary came out as this is going on
because it's literally the
equivalent 20 years ago without social
media and it's just so interesting the
same played out without like with just
like the traditional media amplifying it
versus like today's day and age and like
social media helping to amplify it but I
remember like I was ride or die Spice
Girls also I was like what you know
seven or eight when they were dating and
like I I remember where I was like I
remember the feeling but like you there
was no access to news it was like you're
like reading the newspaper like do you
know what I mean it was just something
that you knew was happening and it was
felt like epic and awesome cuz really
and it's so funny cuz the documentary is
so much about him but like she was like
the star for all of us you know like
yeah we're all like watching for her us
girlies yeah 100% so we can also talk
about the Beckham documentary another
one that I absolutely loved I just
finished it it was so good I had the
same thought that like Posh and Becks
are like Taylor and Travis and so it
would be the equivalent of Taylor and
Travis getting married having four
children and being together for over 20
years like that's [__] crazy it's
crazy yeah no it's absolutely crazy my
gut is that that's not going to happen
but I would love to be wrong about that
100% 100% well and the reason why is
because you can actually see what a good
marriage that David and Victoria have
despite the highs and lows that they've
had which and honestly I thought that
the documentary did a really good job of
like I think that Victoria Beckham is
like such an incredible woman and mom
like what she like put up with so that
her husband could live his dream even
though she was a huge star and then also
I I felt like the documentary actually
didn't really give her a chance to talk
about how she's like built this
incredible fashion line and is still
like you know just as big a very big
name on her own um but you know it all
also goes all the stories are tied
together because it goes back to soccer
I feel like David Beckham coming here
and playing soccer just made like soccer
cool all around you know um cuz that's
like not really our sport in America no
it's so crazy how the whole world like
and I was reading the a lot of the
experts who were on Beckham like if you
read their titles it's like they wrote
books like about the history of soccer
you know how soccer explains the world
like how soccer is a part of world wars
like they stop SE Wars to play their
soccer game and like for us here in the
US it's just like in irrelevant ugly
literally we're like football and we're
obsessed with football yeah do you think
that they will ever be a successful Us
Part like
soccer Endeavor they're trying in Miami
right now like they're trying in Miami
like that's how the documentary ends
David is a part of the Miami team they
have Lionel Messi he just won the World
Cup he's the biggest in 2025 like he
already said he's done he's here for and
he's
out no I just think not resigning I
think he's just going like back to
Europe okay yeah um I don't know I feel
like there's a lot of excitement for it
you know the pink jerseys and stuff yeah
no they've done a really good job
branding Wise It's like electric but you
just can't get people to care like
getting people to care about things that
they don't care about is really
impossible yeah but that's why I think
it's so funny because growing up like
soccer is such a core sport for kids to
play you know I mean that's also like
lacrosse like talk about a dead end
right the professional leagues are NADA
but I I actually think whereas I don't
know about lacrosse but like soccer
feels like it has an opportunity right
now right now but also in general like
there is you know soccer at the Olympics
like you can have a professional career
in soccer I do think like professional
lacrosse players also have other jobs oh
they do I think that they make more of
their money from their job than they do
paying like a hobby but it's like
growing up like it's the most
competitive Sport and then it just
Peters out even in college it's pretty
competitive like depending on where you
go to school 100% yeah know it's weird I
don't nothing waiting for you yeah and I
feel like people have tried like I think
there's a PLL is that like the
professional lacrosse league yeah but
that's also like when David Beckham went
to the Galaxy and he was playing with
guys who like this is their part-time
job and they also you know clean pools
100% David and they were saying like
David Beck's like playing with the pool
cleaner yeah but I think that's where
you have to get like Brands and fans you
have to build like sports is such a
business you know and it's not just
because they were talking a lot about
like even the salary cap like they
didn't have money to play to pay people
you have to get Brands involved they
have to sponsor the stadiums you have to
get people to buy tickets like it's got
to be like a whole ordeal I feel like
all of that business stuff is easier
than getting fans to care I would agree
you like can't pay for that it reminds
me of that episode of mad when that guy
um hired like the da and the boys to do
advertising because he wanted he was
like trying to make a sports League of
his like dumb sports game do you
remember that no no hold on I want it
was like I need to rewatch Mad Men I
really loved that show oh my God so good
it's such a good reat I watched it like
just so long
ago I watched it probably six years ago
so I'm not ready for a we a rewatch
um but it's so good the suitcase uh well
anyways while anyway it was just a
random sport say was like pickle ball
and like someone like was literally
wanted to pay them like millions of
dollars to like advertise for their
sport to like make people care and yeah
well pickle ball is another really
interesting one because that's actually
like people care about it but there's no
business around it yeah you know there's
no like official leag it's not an
Olympic sport is it I don't think so I
feel like it actually might become one
they added a bunch of sports recently
like skateboarding and oh did they yeah
and I feel like you actually have a
better shot of like becoming an Olympic
sport yeah they'll really give you
anything at over at the Olympics there's
another Olympic year That's so exciting
I know in Paris I think lacrosse might
be an Olympic sport I don't well is
lacrosse very much an American sport the
thing about the Olympics is that it has
to be a global sport like we don't play
cro here you know like there has there
it has to be something not an Olympic
sport right because like we only play it
here and they're still trying to make
fetch happen in London and it's just not
happening 10 years later yeah yeah
interesting like I don't even know if
it's been 10 years but there's always a
London game
like as a girly with a husband that ride
or dies for football like you know that
your Sundays from September through
February are shot to hell but really
Eastern Standard Time it doesn't start
until 1 so you can have your morning
with these [__] London Games now the
9:00 a.m. start or 10:00 a.m. start and
it's like give us a [__] break yeah
Sundays and Mondays and Thursdays and
then with college football you have
Fridays and Saturdays and it's like when
are we supposed to watch Love is Blind
it's so true even though now that watch
season I watched in the background of
Zach so I know some of the story lines
cuz like I would he was always watching
it I would like sometimes tune in tune
out um but also now that Claudia and I
are like football fans it's kind of like
not enough football like so many nights
were like is football on tonight no GH
oh my God like I'm really not only have
sports just there's only like two nights
right now that football is isn't on I
think it's like ch's and we're craving
it honestly I find football to right now
e like first of all the sports teams
have just been like so solidly standing
with Israel and so I stand with anyone
who does that but even before that I
just it's very like kind of mind-numbing
like to just watch it and maybe that's
why the men like it and it's like almost
like therapeutic like there's it's just
it's very American no it's like I don't
know it's just it was calming weird oh
really that's so interesting yeah
because usually everyone's like you know
like it's like get him not for me I'm
like you know you do your thing boys you
play beautiful
ball now are you ready for our next
story which I need to get your take on
because number four or number five this
is number four okay great Justin
Timberlake is all over the news as
Britney spears' Memoir Bombshells
continue to be revealed yesterday it was
revealed I know Claudia and Jackie s
spoke about it um she talked about why
she shaped her head she talked about the
fact that she had an abortion when she
was dating Justin Timberlake and now
she's accusing him of cheating on her
with another celebrity in explosive
Memoir after revealing that she had an
abortion with the singer at 19 so
Britney has accused Justin of cheating
on her during their three-year
relationship the singer made the claims
in the upcoming Memoir the woman in me
which will be published on October 24th
Britney who dated Justin from 1999 to
2002 didn't name the person he cheated
on her with referring to her as another
celebrity according to TMZ the star also
said in her book she did not wish to
name the woman because they have a
family and she doesn't want to embarrass
him that's nice that is so nice not so
much grace for him though no no um
so this you know I think we all knew
that Justin diber Lake would be running
and hiding when this Memoir came out so
far it's really not good for him also I
I haven't read like the whole excerpt or
nor the whole book obviously because
it's not out yet but when she talked
about the abortion like she said that
like Justin didn't want to have a baby
and that he said that we're not ready
for parents I don't know how she felt
about it but like that's not a great
look for him and then also like cheater
cheater pumpkin eater yeah he's I think
the reason why you know I think that
that Rel ship obviously I don't know
Britney but I think it did a lot of
damage for her you know and like she was
so young and thrown into the Limelight
in such a major way and I honestly
really feel for her deeply like I just
think that I can't wait to read her book
I love a celebrity Memoir I don't read
much but like 100% I will read this is
making me when when it was all coming
out that she was writing a book and and
really it was like her talking to a
therapist and like someone recording
everything cuz she's notri it aded I was
like I'm not interested but now I'm
becom more interested in hearing like
her story and the circumstances that led
her to where she is right now yeah 100%
And I think for us you know when we were
kids she was the biggest she was like
the Taylor Swift she was the biggest
star on the planet and so it's
interesting to hear about and it was the
same with the Jessica Simpson Memoir
because some of the things that she
talked about like I remember being you
know 9 10 years old and like you know
what I what I saw versus what she
actually experienced and all those
things um so I definitely will be
reading it and I honestly just really
feel for Britney and I think that I'm
glad that she's getting the opportunity
to tell her story listen um if she says
Justin wasn't didn't Justin Timberlake
cheat
on J yeah he was holding another woman's
hand like on a movie something in New
Orleans I feel like out so I don't know
where there's smoke there's fire maybe
obviously I'm not going to say whether
he's a cheater or not because I don't
know but I am ultimately glad that
Britney is able to tell her story her
experience how she viewed it I think
it's going to be you know very cathartic
for her and I think that she she feels
like she hasn't been able to have a
voice for a very long time so I'm glad
that she's getting the opportunity to do
so and I would imagine you know there
were a lot of crazy things that happened
in that time frame that there must be a
lot of crazy stories behind the scenes
because of it right so no I actually
changing my tune I I I'm going to read
this book and I'm taking back to how I
felt like Jessica Simpson's book when it
it was announced she was writing a book
like I didn't have a thought one way or
the other but in the weeks leading up to
the book coming out we had stories every
day about things that were coming out
from the book and it was so interesting
and I read the book and it was one of
the best books I've ever read so I'm
going to give Brit that same chance like
they've pulled me in
congratulations machine you did it you
did it um how does this make you feel
about Justin being an instinct Stan and
the Stan Hood as you said still lives
like where does this fit into that well
one thing interesting to know about me
is that I'm not a Justin Timberlake in
syn Rider die girly I am a JC Shaz all
the way um that's a handsome man yeah I
don't know he was always like my
favorite like my school binder folders
it was just like photos of him like who
was your favorite from Back Street Boys
Jackie I was not a Back Street Boys fan
but if I had to pick someone it would
have been Brian okay Jackie do you just
want me to admit that here that's what I
was waiting for thank you um but yeah no
I love JC I didn't just wasn't my
favorite and it's so funny like when I
think about in sync like I actually
don't think about him like I think about
ji I think about Lance I think about
Joey faton like they're killer amazing
people and Justin Timberlake is just not
really on the radar for me as much as
like you would think just knowing that
of course in the band he was the star
but I wasn't into the star that's so
funny I also just wonder though the
nature of his relationship with other
guys you know I feel like they're all
still friendly they are and they're
working together again I think they're
like kind of putting feelers out to see
if people are interested the back people
interested success and I also think him
like kind of hiding behind his bandmates
right now at a time when like he's about
to become very unpopular but then the
Nostalgia of ins sync like kind of will
buoy that negative press that he's going
to get from this Memoir I I think it's a
little calculated and it's not the worst
idea it's definitely calculated I mean I
also I don't know who can who even knows
what he was going through then just
being you know 19 20 years old like
thrown into the Limelight as well
factual he should write a memoir were
they in Mickey Mouse club together yes
yeah so like God knows what they've been
through you know yeah he should remember
who can you look up all the people that
were in Mickey Mouse club together it's
such a wild interesting list yeah it's
like Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling Jessica
Simpson yep um obviously Britney Britney
Justin there's some other people that
are big names that you would never know
I think Christina Aguilera yeah yeah but
um this is either going to be 100% wrong
or 100% right krie Russell y yeah yeah
which is so interesting cuz you would
never think about her in like a song or
dance sort of way she's just a
straightup serious actress Felicity you
know yeah and Americans which is a good
show see yeah so far we've got
everyone um now the rest of these people
I don't know them yeah I think I looked
it up recently I think Carrie Russell
was like the Shocker yeah she's she's
yeah can you imagine you know each other
since what you're like 12 13 then you're
hoisted into the Limelight then you're
in a relationship you have all these
people like controlling your every move
you know you just don't even know the
mental state of any of these people at
that moment in time but I think that it
obviously greatly impacted Britney and
rightfully so and I'm glad that I'm
excited to read the story from her
perspective yeah agreed yeah now it's
time for our fifth and final story some
more relationship news oh wow real
houses of New York Alum Tinsley Mortimer
is engaged to Robert bovard and she's
getting married next month
tins the tins is engaged and she's
getting married in less than a month
source is close to the socialite tell
page six that she's betrothed to one
Robert bovard and they'll getting
they'll be getting hitched in Palm Beach
Mortimer um was the center of the
celebrity social scene in the early
2000s and she went on to star in Bravo's
real house of New York City which is how
you know we've been talking about her
recently obviously there was Tinsley and
Scott she was engaged to him we really
thought she found her happy ending she
did not but now it seems that she has is
it a businessman B it is cuz he's he
seems to be pretty
lowkey um he's somewhat of a mystery he
proposed with an emerald engagement ring
but it's unclear how long they've been
dating or even exactly when he proposed
but they're getting married in a month
and I'm just really happy for Tinsley to
get married me too now let me ask you a
question is her is she Tinsley Mortimer
Mortimer is a married name right
Mortimer is her married name yeah so she
going to be Tinsley Bard I think so I
think that would be the most respectful
to her new husband like instead of
keeping her old husband's name maybe
she'll be like Tinsley Mortimer Bard
yeah yeah cuz we know her as Tinsley
Mortimer right that's what I'm saying
but also the name Tinsley is unique
enough that she could change her last
name and we know who they were talking
about 100% yeah she's like one name
Wonder Vibes for sure yeah you know I I
I wasn't really and I still don't keep
up with Real Housewives of New York but
um I'm again just happy for anybody
finding their happiness you're so like I
am listen it's
like you know it's hard out here
especially she's really been through it
like you know The Saga of her and Scott
he was a businessman Bo I don't know um
they met while she was on the show Carol
introduced him we actually saw their
first date on the show they were such a
cute couple like he seemed so into her
and she was like so into him and he like
wouldn't really commit to her but then
he like finally did and then they like
broke up cuz he like lives in Chicago
and then they got back together and she
was like [__] it I'm moving to Chicago
she left your house of New York she got
he he proposed to her like she's living
in his pen house in Chicago like the
Fairy Tale come true you know she's the
exception not the rule uh and then like
they split again oh no yeah so she's
really like been through it yeah yeah
yeah for sure so yes I'm I'm very happy
for herle tub yeah happy for tins yeah
okay so now it is time for deer toasters
our weekly advice segment I've got trout
skin here to help give advice before
people want to know why you call me
trout skin by the way oh this is an easy
one um when we were younger like her
name is Olivia obviously so I called her
Oliver and then I thought the or Oliver
Twist like I thought it was Oliver trout
for a second so I was just like calling
her trout um I realized quickly that it
was Oliver Twist but like trout stuck
and then we watched a lot of Hannah
Montana at that time and she was
prattling on about trout skin that's so
Miley Stewart um so once I heard trout
skin on Hannah Montana I started calling
her trout skin the nickname laid dormant
for about 15 years but then when I moved
back I when I moved down here and we're
like spending all this time together
like I just got back into calling you
trout and it's really been a blessing
and a joy totally yeah no people are
like it's disgusting I'm like you don't
even know the origin story okay I call
my sisters trout skin snitch and tury
like take your pick yeah each one is
worse than the next I think trout skin
is actually the best of them all no
turty really is oh but tur is a turd
yeah I think tur's the worst I know but
it's loves it yeah it's so
cute it's so funny I wonder what I would
call myself if I was in charge of my I
feel yeah like you I just call you Jer
like you don't really have nickname CU I
make the nicknam yeah you do you're the
nickname girl so I wonder what my
nickname would be yeah if someone else
was the nickname
person makes you think well dear
toasters and today's episode are brought
to you by ag1 and I'm so glad Olivia is
here on this episode because she could
do the ad because she is a1's number one
fan yes I am so ag1 has everything that
you need dur for your day you drink ag1
in the morning it could be before a
workout while you're making your coffee
it's just a great way to start your day
and will make you feel Unstoppable ready
to take on the day ready to go like
you're doing something good for your
body so ag1 is a foundational nutrition
supplement that delivers comprehensive
nutrients to support whole body Health
it has so many greens nutrients
everything you put it in your bottle
with water Shake It Up Chicago down it
and it gives you everything that you
need for the day can you tell me about
your experience with ag1 because I'm
literally sitting here with a1's number
one fan literally cannot wait for the
code because I buy it full bat myself
because I'm obsessed oh okay I'm glad sh
I am actually ag1 number two fan and AG
One's number one fan is my husband Zach
Shapiro like there will literally never
he will never miss a day like he will
never miss a day we live for ag1 it's so
crazy cuz ever since we started taking
it it's unbelievable you can really feel
the difference like you just feel
brighter like more mental Clarity like
everything flows better and you know I
think as a 30-some it's not always easy
to get all of your vitamins and you know
it's just super important for for all
the reasons why you need all the
different vitamins but you're not going
to go there I think like 75 vitamins and
nutrients in ag1 right like you're not
going to go take 75 pills so like you
have this like green juice essentially
in the morning you know you're doing
good for your body and then you start
the day like I just literally when we
went to New York for Charlie's bris we
didn't bring ag1 with us and Zach made
Margot bring bring it cuz she had it at
her apartment but you know they also
have single serving agon travel packs I
now I have that and I have the the drops
as well no I have everything it's laid
out like there's my coffee bar is like
coffee and then there's ag1 and high
vitamins and the vitamins are for the
kids and the ag1 is for Zach and I and
that's like the morning setup like
everybody just take your vitamins drink
your coffee move on with your day I love
it so if you want to take ownership of
your health try ag1 and get a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free ag1 travel packs with your first
first purchase go to drink a1.com toast
that's drink a1.com toast check check it
out wow my husband's going to be so
[__] excited also today's episode is
brought to you by the farmer's dog so
the results of switching your dog's food
from kibble to Fresh can seem like magic
when a senior dog starts acting like a
puppy again and the pickiest of eaters
can't wait for for dinner time you might
think some spells were cast but the
farmer's dog doesn't use any sorcery or
secret ingredients to make their fresh
food just science so if you don't know
the farmer's dog it makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog food it's developed by
vets nutritionally balanced and made
from real healthy ingredients to human
human food safety standards it's the
best option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canned
goo it's just real healthy food so I
actually was seeing these Farmers dog
videos where they show you like how
kibble gets made and also like why
people started making kibble to begin
with and it's really disgusting um and
it's like we love our strice Brethren
why not strice eating fresh healthy food
like it's a no-brainer once you realize
it you're like oh duh 100% I obviously
don't have a dog but I've actually I've
heard like amazing things amazing things
shinier coat better smelling breath
feeling younger more vibrant it's so so
great for dogs literally it doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health health helping you live
more healthy happy and full years
together a also the farmer dog
commercials just like could bring a tear
to the eye totally that means more
magical moments with your dog but no
actual magic required get 50% off your
first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com
toast plus you get free shipping just go
to thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box plus free shipping that's
a great deal sure is thank you to our
sponsors now it is time sponsors we do
our best we do all right yeah well you
know why it's because I feel like
there's so many great Brands out there
and those are like four amazing Brands
and like perfect representation of all
things that are toast so I love that
thanks well dear toaster is Our advice
segment where we uh take your advice
questions and we give our advice on your
advice questions you can submit to Dear
toasters gmail.com or at the toast
podcast.com um we have a a submission
box and you can take our advice or not
you know yeah take it or leave it yep
first up hi Jacks and mlar asterik Trin
let's bust the elephant in the room how
many girlies are out here on NFL Sunday
having a day of football watching with
their friend/ PE joms and have
absolutely no idea what the [__] is
going on I'm like not a girl to be like
I'm not like other girls of course I
mean I like football have been around it
grown up watching it with my dad my
whole entire life but I could not
explain anything to you beyond the basic
Logistics of the game to save my life am
I stupid also how do men memorize the
name draft your college [__] color of
every player I don't get it I'm stressed
I'm insecure in a social football
setting because I have nothing
intelligent to contribute I guess I'm
just asking for a gauge here from The
Toasters across the ation how much of
watching football is knowing what's
going on for real and how much is
pretending to know also bonus advice how
do you play it well at pretending to
know what a great deer toaster I feel
like I'm the perfect person to answer
this because there a lot of questions in
there so I want to make sure we address
them all so
field right basically what football is
about is you're trying to get from one
end of the field to the other I think
she muste that I'm just starting from
the beginning
okay and you have two different ways you
can score you can score a touchdown
Which is six points and then you kick
for an extra point seven or you could
just kick a field goal and you get three
points essentially the way to get down
the field is you have four downs or four
tries to go 10 yards so first down or
first in 10 is your first try to get to
10 if you then get a second down second
and five that means it's your second try
within the four trying to get the rest
of that five so everything is about you
have four tries to get 10 yards and
you're just trying to get 10 10 10 10 10
all the way down to get to the other end
of the field to score now sometimes you
will be at third and seven or third and
long right and essentially if you don't
get to the marker that you need to get
to you will be at fourth down and what
happens most time on fourth down is the
team doesn't take their fourth chance
they just then kick the ball to the
other team because if you go on four and
you don't get the yardage that you need
so let's say it's Fourth and three and
you need three yards but you you don't
get it then the team gets the other team
gets the ball from exactly where you
left off so what you're always trying to
think about is the position of the other
team to score and then you're
taking basically three three or four
attempts to get all the way down the
field now the one thing that I'll say
about football is it is very confusing
and it's like who came up with that I
always think about that when I'm
watching football I'm like who came up
with these rules and these attempts and
all these things you know what's
confusing to me so on the TV they show
you the line of like what they need to
get past but like how do the players
know where it is cuz like they're always
fighting on the line that's like CGI I
you know what it's so funny I actually I
asked Zach that and I think like that's
just what makes you good at the game
it's the same way when you play tennis
and you know like exactly how hard to
hit it so that it stays in the Baseline
it's like they know where the marker is
in their mind they like know how the
they basically know where they need to
get to you know um but I think the more
you watch the more you
learn you know I think ultimately a lot
of people don't really understand the
nuances of everything that's going on
and I most certainly don't but again no
I really appreciate your your stab at
explaining I kind of got lost in the
middle but I so I'm not so interested in
learning so for this girl one like
listen to Olivia's recap and maybe that
will help I hope it was helpful it's
it's hard to explain you know I mean
it's so confusing like I have a basic
understanding but when it comes to the
first and TS and downs I don't that's
where they lose me but I don't really
like care to know more I'll just let the
announcers explain but what I will say a
good piece of advice like so often Zach
has his sport shows like commentary
shows playing like in you know in the
background of Our Lives um he likes
Colin coward which I don't like he also
watches PTI every day and I'm not saying
you need to go and watch those shows but
like I get so many talking points like
for this show from overhearing it from
those shows or even if you're watching
the game they have like you know the
commentators like just chiming in about
what's going on with the players and
like I get a lot of information that way
so that's a good way to fake it because
then you could be like oh I heard um you
know Christian M like I did hear
Christian mcaffrey said that like Kyle
jues is the fixer of the game like he'll
see the the whole field and the whole
team and he'll figure out a way to to
like fix what's [__] up in their
lineup like good to know also like I
remember you know you can make
interesting trade news based on like
real estate AC Acquisitions like I
remember it was like rumored someone was
going to one team because he bought a
house there like it's just I would pick
up on that then of course chy and I
always love the celebrity element like
you can just watch the game who's dating
a celeb start chatting well I think
what's also that the thing that I wanted
to say that I thought was really
interesting is like how do they know
every player what team they played on
what team they previously played on what
freaking College they went to and just
like think about it in the terms of the
bachelor right like think about how many
literally dozens of Bachelor contestants
you know you know how far they got like
and we only watch them like for three
months and one season yeah and like
because they're watching every single
week they're reading news about it
they're read seeing listening to
podcasts about it they're watching you
know Sports commentator programs about
it like this is basically not to make
like an even comparison but this is
basically like their B Bachelor so they
know the ins and outs of it and that's
why they're able to memorize all the
information Real Housewives is also a
good touch point and it's also like we
know the Bachelor Real Housewives V pum
rules Every Love is Blind cast member
like all these shows that we watch and
like you can name the person how many
Instagram followers what they're up to
that's what they do with that's what
they do and they've been doing it since
they were young and they actually watch
like way more hours of their people than
we watch of ours yeah yeah exactly also
it will be helpful that now that the
toast is a Sports Broadcast like you can
get some information here and um it's
football is really like it is difficult
to explain I think the more that you
watch it the more that you will learn um
but there's always like there's a lot of
things that are so unclear safety this I
just feel like you don't have to get
into the weeds of the game there are so
many like ancillary things about
football that you could be contributing
to like a football chili maybe you bring
your chili and it's about your chili you
maybe this person really wants to like
understand football like she wants to be
a football girly you know yeah but I
just feel like there are other ways to
like fudge it and get involved in the
game without like knink the Spritz you
know yeah so like bring the spritzes to
the game watching party talk about the
celebrity connections you know
regurgitate something that you heard on
the Sports Broadcast you know bar schol
has a lot of sports shows and I think
those guys are funny so that's like a
good funny thing my husband listens to
part of my take every day that's like
his do you do you hear it because he's
listening to it where sometimes but he
is very respectful like when we get in
the car and his phone automatically
plays he has to change it to either The
Little Mermaid or Beauty and the Beast
in order to you know be a functioning
member of our car no I'm always having
like Colin coward in my head I've never
even heard of that person yes you have
he's such a huge Sports guy really and
Zach always watches him and I just like
really I don't know why I do not like
him and I I think his takes stink
honestly I mean honestly respect like I
feel you I don't even know him but yeah
he does a segment that I um that I
respect and it's like you know Sports
people they make all their predictions
and sometimes they're right sometimes
they're wrong and he does a segment
called where Colin was right and where
Colin was wrong like just oh I love the
self-a awareness yeah me too yeah you
definitely know this guy he does the
show The Herd with Colin cow herd I'm
going to show you picture don't but show
me a picture he's nice looking gu I know
Scott Hansen from NFL Red Zone never
seen him in my life
Wow what channel ESPN yeah I think so
it's like the one of the biggest shows
my husband will be disappointed in me
but it is what it
is okay next one dear Jackson Claude
Aster live I live for deer toasters I'm
actually in a situation where I need to
write in for help my dad has always told
me that he'll pay for my wedding as long
as I don't live with my fiance before we
get married well I got engaged in August
and my lease for my apartment ends in
November we don't get married until June
2024 and he never fails to remind us
that we can't live together until we're
married so I have two choices one
respect my dad's wishes and move in with
a friend or my brother for 7 months so I
can still go stay with my fiance
whenever I want or two tell my dad to
[__] off and move in with my fiance
since he already gave me the wedding
money I want my wedding paid for but I
want to be an independent as a
27-year-old and live my life without
feeling like my parents still control my
life please help I think like both
options are totally fine personally like
when I um was engaged and didn't wasn't
going to like you know get into a new
solo apartment but wasn't going to move
in with Zach until we were married I
moved home so that would be the
equivalent of like you living with your
brother or a friend and it was nice I
spent all my time actually no I'm sorry
Zach and I you were living together when
you got engaged but we couldn't live
together until we got engaged so until
we got engaged I lived at home because I
wasn't going to get another apartment on
my own so this is just like a little bit
further down the road but I think it's
like I think if you if you already have
the wedding money like sure you could
Sher what your dad says but yeah but
like do you really want to have like
drama with your dad no especially not
around your wedding which is a happy
time I think listen if it's so beyond
important to you to live with your
fiance before you're married then you
should just really sit down with your
dad and just lay out your points like
this is why it's important to me and I
think just being really respectful and
say I really respect why you feel the
way that you do and I don't want I just
want to explain my side of like why this
is important to me or why I feel
strongly I think that's fruitless like
her dad feels this way he's Felt This
Way forever it's always been the rule
like trying to change his mind I I know
but sometimes there's Nuance there right
because like if your dad really likes
the guy that she's with you know what I
mean like he's a good guy like I
wouldn't just take the money and run
because I just don't think that that's
going to have you let you have a good
relationship with your dad in the future
personally I would play by the rules I
would wait to 7 months i' move in with a
friend or a brother spend all my time at
my fian the one other thing here is like
do you need your dad's money for the
wedding you know even if she could do it
on her own it's super helpful to have
help I mean of course I'm just saying
like you know weigh all the options yeah
I would I would play by the rules it's
seven months it's not a big deal and
it'll mean a lot to your
dad I think you could do it I think so
too I'm also a fan of sit down with your
dad and just give it one last hurah you
know know yeah even if it's fruitless
you know I just think sometimes just
having like a face Toof face
conversation like this is important to
me I understand your point I you know I
think people just like want to be
understood and heard and then obviously
everybody can go and make their own
decisions but keep us posted yeah they
they do sometimes next one Jackson tury
L asri trout skin Lou longtime listener
I truly think of you GES as part of my
family I listen so often thank you I
need your help my husband is an engineer
and tells these very technical stories
that seem to never end how do I
respectfully tell him to shut the [__]
up and not discuss at length these
granular detailed horrifically specific
and boring stories about work without
being a [__] of a wife we've been
married 5 years together for 10 he's a
pum in all other aspects of life
oh I think you just have to like grin
and bear it I don't know how you could
say that like one without hurting his
feelings and two with being effective
like people are the way that they are I
was just G to say men are horrific at
like telling stories sharing the
opposite issue like I only get like if
I'm like what what's the tea what
happened to like I get one word so you
know we all have our crosses to bear
telling me a story literally yesterday
about work and like both of the women
like had the same name and he like
wasn't distinguishing between them and I
was like what the [__] are you talking
about you know like I just feel like men
are really shitty communicators whether
they overc communicate or underc
communicate and I think maybe it might
be helpful for you to like just tell
your husband like I really like feel
free to tell me all these stories all
the time like I don't actually
understand what you're talking about
that's not what she like I don't think
it's that understanding it's like she's
bored to tears no I know but like and
also if he takes more time to explain
like that's a longer story worse yeah
yeah I feel like you could I some like I
think this is something you just have to
accept but sometimes you could be like
what's the gist or like what's the
bottom line TDR TDR me it's kind of like
those friends that you have and I know
you know exactly who I'm talking about
when like you call them and you straight
up just leave the phone and put it on
mute and walk away you know but obvious
you can't that never done that oh my God
what are you doing I've never I well I'm
not super close with people who like
tell Dreadful stories because like that
is a PPP of mine I'll tell you who I do
that with because like I just cannot but
that's besides a point point is um if
you have an amazing husband and this is
his fatal flaw then you probably girly
have to suck it up cuz it could be
10,000 times worse I agree and I think
it's actually very sweet that he wants
to tell you every nitty-gritty shitty
detail of his ultimately it's a sweet
trait and that he wants to like explain
these technical things so that like you
understand and that you maybe you you
can like have these conversations like
while you're cooking or like doing
laundry so like you can pretend you're
listening but you're not actually and
you could also like be being productive
it's not like you just like lost all
these this time right just sitting there
on the couch like listening to
granularity about engineering yeah I
mean it would bore me to tears too I get
it I would be like shut the [__] up yeah
no but it sounds like such a great guy
listen like would you rather this be his
fatal flaw or something else you know
it's true you know it's so it's there's
is wonderful you know it is it's a it's
a luxury it is a luxury so best of luck
to you too but like hang on to this one
he sounds like a good guy he does but
I'm sure you know it it can be maybe you
can hook up with the girl who initially
wrote in about football and her husband
can give a granular descri talk to each
other yeah about you know all the
details no I'm kidding yes well thank
you so much trout skin it's over so um
let everyone know where they can follow
you engage with your life if they want
more trout I hope you do um it would be
@ Olivia ASR on Instagram I am not on
Tik Tok because I am too old and I don't
know how to use it um do you scroll on
do you have like a Tik Tok that you
consume yeah user 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
yep that's me 100% but you know I still
see the same content on reals like two
weeks later so is it really two weeks as
someone who like does both um I would
say it's probably it's like eight days
and the reason why I know that is
because my husband then sends me stuff
and I'm like I saw this already you know
and it's really just usually a little
over a week out okay um yeah but yeah no
um at aash like follow me if you like me
and if you don't you don't have to
follow me and that's very cool um and I
respect your wishes to follow whoever
you wish yeah well thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show we love we just
like go like this
like I I do my outro different than
Claud like like thank you so much for
listening to the toast Please Subscribe
follow us wherever you can do those
things please leave a five-star review
about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented that we are and have
an amazing day we love you so much love
you bye